as Russia's war against Ukraine rages on
and more civilians are killed in attacks
like these it now seems clearer than
ever that Ukraine is about to strike
back in a way it hasn't it more than 15
months we know the ukrainians have
prepared their forces and that it should
come very soon that much awaited
counter-offensive which the secretary of
the country's National Security and
defense Council told BBC is coming
in a rare and exclusive interview Alexi
danielov told the broadcaster it could
happen tomorrow the day after or in a
week but you're ready
recapturing lost territory is key for
Ukraine and time matters because support
from Ukrainian allies isn't guaranteed
indefinitely there is a danger of War
fatigue so the the Ukrainian offensive
that could actually bring a sooner end
of the war is really important for
Ukraine and for the world nice to meet
you in Kiev Vladimir zielinski expressed
his gratitude to the United States a
major supplier of military aid and
foreign influence thank you very much
thanks bipartisan support Congress it's
the best money we've ever spent
Republican senator Lindsey Graham met
Ukraine's president as America's own
debt ceiling deadline ticked closer
Graham said there could be no backing
off of Financial and Military Support
for Ukraine now but I expect in the
coming days and weeks for the Ukrainian
counter-offensive to yield results it is
extremely important that Ukraine do well
in this offensive A month's plan counter
punch Ukraine hopes will hasten the end
of this war shuttle Shea Global News